and I told you about ass it's coming out
on every console ever inmate check it
out link in description
hello and welcome you suck
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry okay how
about something lighter you're not that
great sorry for sounding a bit smug I
promise I mean well don't worry I'm not
that great either okay so let's just say
it together I suck I had pretty much
everything you're not even saying it out
loud listen I don't actually care about
helping you here it's just that this is
something that I've learned from being a
high profile personality online over the
couple years and that is it's better to
just acknowledge that you're not that
great and I don't mean it in a self
destructive kind of way I'm just talking
about ego it's something that I used to
struggle with or at least I think it's a
constant struggle when you are this
handsome that was a funny joke right for
someone that's gone through somewhat of
an ego trip I think it's so easy to spot
when other people are going through it
and it's such an ugly behavior that I
can't even sympathise with the person
going through it and a lot of times I
criticize through videos when these sort
of things happen we don't need to get
into any names okay when I first
received my first bit of hate or
criticism I'm gonna use the term hate
very loosely in this video because
that's how I think people do in general
and that's kind of a problem in itself
when I ever see my first bit of hate I
was about six seven years ago and I had
just been making videos and it was just
me and my audience and no one had really
sort of interfered with that and we just
had our own special group and bubble and
it was it was a beautiful time honestly
looking back but then I did get
criticized for being squeaky beats
creaky humor sexual can't like sexual
jokes for kids and inappropriate humor
in general and very childish and I I
just was not equipped to handle it I
never faced any sort of criticism
especially in the way they as ruthless
as the Internet can be as well you might
be criticized by one person
but then a whole army of the internet
cut sort of joins in my sort of first
reaction to it was mm-hmm
there's nothing wrong with me okay
there's something wrong with you and why
by the way why are you even criticizing
me if you don't like my content then
don't watch it and that's a classic ego
response I think because you're sort of
saying that oh I'm above criticism just
because you don't like me it's your
problem and not mine and it makes sense
and that's sort of the sentiment that's
been carried out I think for a long time
that you should just brush off hate
comments and never pay attention to them
in retrospect and looking back I'm
really glad I listened to hate comments
I'm really glad I I was able to pick out
at least what I thought I could improve
on and I think if I didn't do that I
probably wouldn't even keep making
videos at this point because I would
either number one let all the hate
actually build up and get to me our
number two I wouldn't just stay the same
I would have done the same super squeaky
content as I've always done and no one
would care to watch that for for that
long at least so I feel pretty sure that
that wouldn't be the case and I also
think that it made me want to improve I
think opening up in a way it made me
improve on things that I never thought I
would improve on it made me learn things
that I never thought I would learn
thanks to hate comments so I sort of
wanted to make this video to open up
that idea into people's mind that maybe
it's not all that bad I'm not ignoring
the fact that some are just straight up
garbage comments that you should 100%
ignore I'm just saying that if you are
honest with yourself and you are honest
with your ideas then you have the at
least the ability to tell that apart
because if you're honest with yourself
complete as well as you can at least
then if someone calls you out on
something or some type of behavior then
you can look at yourself more critically
instead of immediately going into
defense mode or there's nothing wrong
with me mode there's something wrong
with you and for an example I don't mean
to keep dragging on the Logan Paul thing
but I think it's a it's an interesting
one because his first response just that
it was
very different from his video that he
made that and I think you can tell just
like I did a few years ago he went
through the same mind thing mindset of
wanting to defend yourself versus maybe
I'm not that great well we saw how long
that lasted but still if you really
think about it hate comments can be free
unbiased criticism that you receive
anonymously which you won't get from
even your closest friends most likely at
least and I think a lot of times when
you see celebrities are online
personalities surrounded by big groups
that's when they usually have a big ego
problem because there's no one there to
call them out on their behavior I think
a lot of times hate comments can be a
really useful tool it just comes in a
very very ugly shape I'm not ignoring
that obviously it's important to have
confidence and self-esteem I'm not
saying you shouldn't have that but I
think deciphering or listening to it
comments I've honestly given me that
because I can honestly and confidently
tell them apart
I can tell apart if someone's being an
idiot or if there's actually something
valuable in there and this is sort of
the point I'm trying to make here is
that a lot of times you might get a
really bad comment that might make you
feel really really uncomfortable and
they might contain X Y & Z but then
maybe let's say Z is really valuable
constructive criticism I don't like
being criticized I can just brush this
off completely because x & y was makes
this a hate comment does this make any
sense at all you're sort of using their
own weapon against them anyway maybe I'm
trying to do a more positive spin on
this and their wrists but I this is just
from my experience I'm sure not everyone
is like this taking criticism is very
uncomfortable but I think it's important
to at least open yourself up just for a
second of that feeling I'm uncomfortable
and sort of just play with that thought
instead of just completely throwing it
away because I think that can lead to
really dangerous behavior and which I'll
get into in a second and don't get me
wrong it's hard it's really hard to take
hate comments and I think I I sort of
categorize them in in four different
shapes number
one is to straight-up dumb hate comments
that are just trying to make you feel
bad and there's nothing else in there
just ignore those number two it's the
ones that are ignorant and hateful maybe
they base some sort of judgment on you
and they don't know something that you
know just ignore that as well there
there's nothing valuable there obviously
as well number three I noticed some
comments disguise himself as
constructive criticism but really it's
just a vicious attempt to seem like
they're not trying to cause you harm but
they are in fact trying to do that just
go ahead and ignore those as well and
number four which is hate comments
trying to drag you down but actually
contain valuable criticism that's the
one that I think it is least worth to
consider and even then you have to be
very critical of they listen I never
said it was easy because obviously
you're not supposed to just couldn't
form to what anyone else wants you to be
you're not just supposed to listen oh oh
I did that wrong maybe I should do this
you sort of have to figure that out
yourself I think if I just listened to
all the criticism I got by the media and
to be fair a lot of it has been valid
criticism and that's why I realized when
I have to confess to it I as opposed if
I listen to all of it I would literally
just be another celebrity with no
opinion and thoughts on my own that went
outside the the mainstream media
narrative at least it wouldn't have been
honest it wouldn't have been honest to
who how I think and Who I am
so the key point here is really honesty
and I'm not saying drive yourself mad by
listening to hate comments all the time
that's not it at all but this is just
something you sort of have to learn if
you want to be an internet personality
or I don't know in general they might be
worth it I don't know it's really great
trying to prove a point by saying I
don't know by opening up yourself to the
idea that maybe I'm not that great you
sort of open up your self to improve and
if you don't do that and if you
completely just throw it away then like
I said you run into probably a lot of
issues along the line you're not just
cheating how you look at yourself but
you also have to start cheating how the
whole world is different because you
have to defend your ego for example this
is why Amy Schumer thinks that the
reason because her TV show did poorly is
because of
far right-wing politics and not because
maybe it wasn't that great
imagine having to tell yourself that
instead of just questioning yourself
alright maybe my movie wasn't that great
and maybe there's some valid criticism
here that I can improve for my next
movie oh look at that
then her next movies doing super bad as
well think about it this way you cannot
become great if you already know that
you are and if you don't want to do any
of this that's fine most likely you
probably will never have to even but I
think it's a valuable lesson for a lot
of YouTube personalities or internet
celebrities in general I see a lot of my
even favorite creators really struggled
with this and like I said I think since
I went through it I could tell what
other people are and it's just a shame
and I'm not saying I'm completely
without an ego either I think everyone
needs some sort of level of it at least
but I think that the fact that we have
adopted this idea that all hate comments
are just inherently bad is actually
really harmful and I think that's what
creates really insane people deep down
we all know that we're not that great
whether we want to admit that or not and
unless you accept that you will
absolutely lower your chance of ever
becoming something more than what you
already are yes you suck thank you for
listening I don't know if this was
helpful at all but it's just some
thoughts I wanted to share goodbye if
you're an influencer or creator with an
ego problem contact PewDiePie for a
personal therapy consultation today by
calling five five five
[Music]